après les orages du week-end les
sinistrés tourangeau enquête
d'indemnisation là où le vent et la
grêle ont frappé les des toitures et des
voitures ont été endommagées ce soir
ballan-miré demandent la reconnaissance
de l'état de catastrophe naturelle et
les vignerons l'aide de l'état samuel
colin
il ya plus de feuilles a pu de raisin il
ya là je ramasse rien du tout en fait il
aura suffi d'une vingtaine de minutes
sous le village de koto sur loire cette
vigneronne ne peut que constater les
dégâts et sa part celles ravagées comme
une trentaine d'autres hectares de
cultures ici le raisin commence à
noircir le coup est rude après la
tempête de samedi c'est une année de
récolte de perdus c'était noir noir noir
d'un coup il s'est mis à pleuvoir à des
gouttes très très forte et un coût des
dettes de la petite graine de la grosse
grêle et là j ça y est ça c'est mort
c'est pour nous la grêle et l'orage vont
continuer leur chemin pour toucher en
milieu d'après-midi ballan-miré aux
portes de tours les rafale vont
littéralement couché ce cèdre d'une
vingtaine de mètres le vent a basculé à
l'opposé des vents dominants et l'arbre
l'arbre s'est couché en se couchant il a
endommagé
ils endommagent et les autres puits est
bon la clôture le portail cet habitant
doit finalement escalader pour rentrer
chez lui ballan miré sous des trombes
d'eau pour la seconde fois de la journée
après un fort orage à 4 heures du matin
j'ai adressé un courrier au ministre de
l'intérieur ce matin le maire de la
ville fait sa demande de reconnaissance
de catastrophe naturelle des tuiles qui
ont été cassées des velux qui ont été
cassées des mobiliers de jardin en
dommage également et naturellement les
voitures qui ont dormi à l'extérieur
deux tiers de la ville auraient été
touchés par la grêle samedi et les
habitants ont un délai de cinq jours
après l'arrivée du sinistre pour
s'adresser aux assurances